c'est l'heure du goûter au centre de
loisirs de Coignières un goûter un peu
spécial car ce mercredi on inaugure la
section primaire de la farandole le tout
nouveau bâtiment en bois fait face à la
section maternelle ouverte en 2006 des
locaux de 400 mètres carrés des espaces
de jeux modulables plus spacieux de
grande fenêtres et des couleurs
chaleureuses alors ce jour-là c'était
jour de fête c'est un moment un petit
peu spécial et partage et en plus ils
ont ils ont la présentation de leur
petit film qu'ils ont fait par rapport à
leur projet théâtre donc ils sont très
impatients de le montrer aux élus et
c'est voilà surexciter là je les trouve
très calme parce que toute l'après-midi
ça a été un peu la surexcitation les
élus présents ont pu découvrir des
cénètes sur les règles de vie du centre
ou encore des chorégraphies
poubelle en plus du théâtre les enfants
pourront bientôt s'initier à
l'environnement avec un jardin potager
et un hôtel à insectes le bâtiment
répond d'ailleurs en partie aux règles
HQ une volonté verte de la mairie qui se
félicite des nouvelles possibilités
qu'offre le centre des facilités des
passerelles plus facile avec le primaire
l'ensemble du centre le permettant donc
je pense qu'effectivement il y a des
projets ambitieux qui vont se mettre en
place dans les mois qui viennent le fait
de pouvoir aussi faire face à un plus
grand nombre si nécessaire était une
condition intéressante pour
inaugurer et faire ce centre
complètement
60 enfants sont déclarés dans le
primaire mais le bâtiment peut en
accueillir 20 supplémentaires ils ont
quitté l'école Bouvet pour prendre place
dans leur nouveau locaux aux vacances de
Noël et depuis ça s'amuse allez la
journée se termine à la farandole il est
temps pour les parents de venir les
chercher